لقد ذهب كل شيء كما يقولون،
دارنا أصبحت الآن مدينة الموتى
ولم يكن هناك وقت للوداع الأخير
هنا
أمي ترقد بسلام حيث رسمت
تلك الأم ذات يوم في
مدينة لمدة 90 دقيقة وترك أهلها
يثرثرون
هنا الحزن باقٍ في الهواء،
نعم
وجوه تحكي عن الرعب الذي نجوا منه وفقدهم، لم
يستوعبوا بعد أن أكرم
فقد عائلة أخيه بأكملها،
وهو الآن يجلس حيث كان منزلهم قائمًا ذات يوم، إنه
كل ما تبقى منهم،
ماذا عن المنزل
الذي بحث عن جثثهم في كل مكان
في المستشفيات وبجوار البحر
ينهار أكرم وهو يحاول أن
يتذكر مكالمته الأخيرة مع شقيقه قبل
يومين فقط من وقوع الكارثة،
ويقول إن هذه مشيئة الله، إنها مشيئة
قاسية كان عليهم قبول
[موسيقى] أجنبية
هنا فقدوا عائلتهم واحدًا تلو الآخر.
شاركونا قصصهم المؤلمة
كيف حمل ابنه البالغ من العمر عشر سنوات
وقفز من سطح إلى آخر
هربًا من الفيضان العنيف الذي ساعد في
إنقاذ العائلات لكنه لم يتمكن من إنقاذ عائلته، فقد
عبد الله والدته وزوجته
وولديه الآخرين  إجمالي 25 من أفراد الأسرة
لكنه دفن أربعة فقط.
الجميع هنا في مهمة للعثور على
الموتى.
ليس هناك ما يكفي من فرق البحث والإنقاذ،
معظمهم من المتطوعين الذين يحفرون
بين الأنقاض الموحلة لهذه
المنازل،
ويطلقون على المارة اسمًا للانضمام إليهم،
ويعتقدون أن هناك شخصًا واحدًا.  ويقولون
إنهم يستطيعون شم المزيد من الجثث تحت الأنقاض،
لكن معظم الجثث ليست هنا.
ويقول المسؤولون إن الآلاف جرفوا
مع منازلهم وفي سياراتهم إلى
الواجهة البحرية المثالية للبحر الأبيض المتوسط، وهي الآن
منطقة انطلاق حيث يتم تسليم
الموتى ولكن  لم يكن لدى ألدي الوقت الكافي
لمعالجة ما نجت منه، فهي
هنا منذ يوم الاثنين الماضي لإعداد
الموتى للدفن،
وهذا هو أصعب شيء اضطرت
إلى القيام به على الإطلاق، وتقول إنها تعرفت على
الوجوه الميتة لأصدقاء العائلة والجيران
في مقبرة خارج المدينة  حيث تم
دفن أكثر من ألف ضحية في المقابر الجماعية، فإنهم يستعدون
لمزيد من
العائلة هنا فقط الغرباء الذين يصلون من أجل
الموتى
ولكن ليس هناك وقت لوقف الجثث،
فقط استمر في القدوم